in this case just to make this connection with Choy representations there are a couple of implications that we can immediately draw from this way of
looking at Choy representations one is that because the choice state is a density Matrix assuming that f is a
valid Channel we conclude that the Choy representation of fi must be positive semi-definite remember that it's a
requirement that we place on channels that they always transform density matrices into density matrices and this
is just one special case of this the second implication is that if we take the choice state for any channel fi and
then discard the output system y then we must be left with the completely mixed state on the input system X that's
because applying a channel to a system and then throwing the resulting system into the garbage is equivalent to just throwing the original system into the
garbage and if we were to do that with our maximally entangled State the density Matrix we'd be left with would
be the identity Matrix divided by n or in other words the completely mixed state for the system X the idea in more
mathematical terms is that composing any Channel with the trace on the output system must be equal to the trace on the
input system and that's because channels must preserve Trace by virtue of the fact that they're linear mappings that
always transform density matrices into density matrices once we have this equation we can clear the denominator n
from both sides to get a slightly cleaner condition in words performing the partial trace on the output system
of the Choy representation of a channel must give us the identity Matrix on the input system so in summary Cho
representations of channels are always positive semi-definite and if we Trace out the output system we're necessarily
left with the identity Matrix on the input system as a turns out these are not only necessary conditions but
they're also sufficient meaning that if I is some arbitrary linear mapping and these two conditions both happen to be
true then it must in fact be that fi is a valid Channel and we'll see why that is the case by the end of the lesson
let's take a look at a few examples starting with the completely def phasing channel to compute the Choy representation it's just a matter of
evaluating the formula the completely defacing Channel leaves k a bra B alone when a equal B and otherwise the output
is zero so the terms in the sum that survive are the ones where a equals B and the result is expressed on the
screen using direct notation we can also view it as a block Matrix Delta leaves diagonal entries alone and zeros out off
diagonal entries and so we're left with a matrix having ones in the upper left and lower right hand Corners with all of
their entries being zero and that's consistent with the first expression for another example let's consider the completely depolarizing Channel again we
can start by writing down the formula and just like in the previous example we don't get any contribution to the sum
when a is not equal to B and this time when a equals B we get the completely mixed state and we can simplify that to
obtain 1/2 * the 2x2 identity Matrix tensor to itself which is 1/2 * the 4x4
identity Matrix we can also think about it in terms of block matrices and naturally we get the same result and as
a last example let's consider the identity channel for a single Cubit it's an easy one here's the formula and of
course the identity Channel doesn't do anything at all and we can think of the result as being twice the density Matrix associated with a f+ state and that's
consistent with what we expect by thinking about the choice state of this Channel and here it is as a block Matrix notice in particular that the Choy
representation of the identity channel is not the identity matrix it's this Matrix we've now seen three different
ways to represent channels in mathematical terms namely Stein spring representations cross representations and Choy
representations and we also have the definition of a channel which is that a channel is a linear mapping that always
transforms density matrices into density matrices even when the channel is applied to just part of a compound system a very natural and very important
question to ask at this point is how do we know these things are all equivalent for instance how do we know that every
mapping described by any one of these representations is in fact a valid Channel and how do we know that we're not leaving any channels out the
remainder of the lesson describes how all of this can be reasoned mathematically if you're willing to accept the equivalence of these things and you're not interested in how it can
be reasoned then you should feel free to skip the rest of the video but I personally think the argument is pretty
slick and it's a good example of a particular style of mathematical proof that comes up from time to time in the theory of quantum information I won't go
through all of the details some of them I'll leave for you or you can find them in the written content for this lesson where everything is is written out in
detail but I do hope to present a reasonably clear picture of how it all works what we want to do is to prove the
equivalence of a collection of statements and the way that we can do this is to set up a cycle of implications in particular we'll start
with the definition of a channel meaning a linear mapping that always transforms density matrices into density matrices
from this definition we can reason that the Choy representation of this channel must satisfy the two conditions we've
already discussed and in fact we've already done this this this was discussed in the context of the choice state of a channel we then forget all
about the definition and we work from the Choy representation and given our two conditions on Choy representations we conclude that there must exist a
cross representation of the mapping fi we then do an analogous thing we forget about Choy representations and we work
from an arbitrary cross representation and from it we can reason that there must be a Stein spring representation for the mapping fi and by the way these
arguments will be mechanical in some sense which allows us to actually perform the conversions according to the arrows for specific channels if we want
to do that the last implication is to reason that if we have a Stein spring representation for a mapping fi then
that mapping must in fact be a valid Channel and again we already did that this time in the context of Stein spring
representations altogether these four implications reveal that these four things are all equivalent because you can start from any one of them and
follow the implications transitively to get to any of the other ones we'll start with the first implication
which is that if we have a channel fi meaning a linear map that always transforms density matrices into density matrices then it has a Cho
representation that satisfies the two conditions that we identified earlier namely that it's positive semi-definite
and if we Trace out the output system we get the identity on the input system and as I mentioned a moment ago we've
already covered this implication in the context of choice States in particular when we divide the Cho represent ation of a channel by n the number of
classical states of the input system then we get a density Matrix and moreover the reduced state of the input
system X for that state is the completely mixed state or in other words the identity Matrix divided by n clearing the denominator gives us our
two conditions so this implication is pretty quick and easy because we already covered